26e jour de guerre en ukraine les russes
bombarde de plus en plus intensément des
villes comme marioupol l'ukraine a
rejeté l'ultimatum de moscou qui
exigeait la capitulation de cette ville
stratégique du sud à kiev un centre
commercial a été bombardée la nuit
dernière le bilan est d'au moins huit
morts on retrouve dans la capitale
ukrainienne john allan walsh bonsoir
johnattan vous avez été avec une unité
de la police dans la gare de kiev
aujourd'hui et ce sont eux qui chasse
les infiltrés russe
oui il faut comprendre que c'est un
filtre est ce qu'on appelle ici les
saboteurs sur la hantise des défenses de
sécurité l'ukrainienne ils ont été très
actifs probablement plus actifs
qu'aujourd'hui au début de l'invasion
russe le président ukrainien crédit et
même d'être assassiné au début au début
de la guerre par ses parts s'est
infiltrée par ces saboteurs et vous
l'avez dit nous avons suivi une unité de
police chargé de lait de les détecter
dans la gare centrale de kiev un point
de transit évidemment stratégique dans
la capitale ukrainienne et il faut
signaler d'ailleurs au passage ça peut
paraître surprenant que malgré la guerre
les trains continuent à fonctionner et
continue à relier l'ouest du pays à la
capitale alors nous avons donc suivi
cette cette unité ces policiers qui ont
qui ont longuement sillonné la guerre
avec nous qu'ils qui contrôlait les
passagers les passants qui ouvrait les
sacs qui vérifiaient les papiers
d'identité il y avait également une de
ces policières avec nous qui avait un
chien chargé de de détecter les
explosifs dans l'est dans les sacs et
les bagages et et ses trains qui
arrivent dans la capitale ukrainienne
arrive donc en grande partie en majorité
de le vif la grande ville de l'ouest
près de la frontière polonaise et ce
sont dans ces trains que des volontaires
arrivent pour participer à la défense de
kiev et de sa périphérie et nous avons
rencontré devant la gare de volontaires
français c'est assez rare de croiser ces
volontaires étrangers à kiev ces deux
volontaires à qui nous avons parlé était
d'ailleurs dans le centre de formation
de volontaires internationaux qui a été
bombardé à lviv près de près de lviv
dans l'ouest de l'ukraine ils nous ont
parlé pendant quelques minutes de leur
motivation l'un était un ancien
légionnaire un ancien membre de la
légion étrangère l'autre venez pour
devenir médecin médecins de de guerre et
tous deux nous ont vraiment dit leur
grande détermination à participer à la
défense de la capitale qui te quitte
même à y perdre la vie s'il le fallait
merci de nat and joe natale